this kind of fraud is costing Americans
as much as 90 billion dollars a year the
affordable care act is one of the
strongest health care anti-fraud bills
in American history we've got some
really folks we're out there stealing
now as today's report shows our
anti-fraud efforts recovered 4.1 billion
dollars last year 2012 was a record year
for fighting Medicare fraud just like
the year before it the Health and Human
Services Department credits the
Affordable Care Act with launching a
half billion dollar effort to bolster a
nationwide network of strike forces
coordinated by a sophisticated
anti-fraud prevention system so is
Obamacare really pulling the plug on
fraud beyond the headlines and press
conferences not much has changed today
I'm pleased to announce that the Justice
Department and our law enforcement
partners have reached an historic three
billion dollar resolution with the
pharmaceutical manufacturer
GlaxoSmithKline LLC got that
three-quarters of this year's record
recovery stems from the resolution of a
lawsuit that began a decade ago for
fraud first committed during the Clinton
administration but if you still think
the bureaucrats have the upper hand on
the fraudsters think again four billion
dollars is a tiny drop in an ocean of
fraud America's biggest scam is getting
bigger than ever we're expected to spend
50 or 60 billion dollars expanding
health insurance so that's smaller
that's less the entirety of Obamacare
and its first year in operation is less
than we see on the lower end estimates
of Medicare and Medicaid fraud the
second year of Obamacare they're going
to spend about a hundred and five
billion that's really that's probably
about the same as we're as we see each
year in total Medicare Medicaid fraud so
if you know one way to think about this
is we could be paying for Obamacare
every year if we weeded out all of the
fraud and abuse in the system Medicare
and Medicaid are two giant programs
you know the IRS runs the tax system
it's very centralized the records are
all centralized Social Security's runs
the security system all the records are
centralized the risks of sort of
fleecing a public system probably or not
as great
you know the penalties are gonna be what
disbarment from the program very very
rarely does somebody actually go to jail
over this and for as long as medicare
has been an easy target for fraud
politicians have searched in vain for a
way to clean up the system because waste
fraud and abuse and Medicare is so
rampant and because it's there's so much
money there it's just a big pot of money
politicians have been going after it for
a while because they either want to save
it or spend it we went after medical
fraud in Medicare and Medicaid very
aggressively more aggressively than ever
before
over the past four years we have
assigned more Justice Department of
prosecutors and more FBI agents to fight
healthcare fraud than ever before I
won't support the Congress in this
effort to deal with a widespread fraud
waste and abuse of our Medicaid system
politicians have tried over the years to
create incentives for providers to go
after it criminally and none of these
approaches seem to really work you get a
maybe a few billion dollars here and
there which is not nothing but in a
program but in a program where we're
talking about 60 70 maybe a hundred
billion dollars worth of fraud abuse
wasted money every year catching three
or four billion dollars just really
isn't getting at the root of the problem
my own personal opinion is one of the
problems is nobody's money's at risk
Medicare and Medicaid basically our
giant bill paying machines and they're
paying claims out of the Treasury
effectively so I personally think
private insurers are more likely than
the other money arrests to catch up with
us quickly enter a new 77 million dollar
fraud prevention system to detect
criminals and coordinate law enforcement
it's the same kind of computer network
that has been used by credit card
companies to stop fraud for years HHS
Secretary Kathleen Sebelius says it will
stop fraud before it happens so last
year we issued a solicitation for
state-of-the-art analytic tools to help
predict and identify fraudulent claims
as soon as
submitted so we can actually stop the
payment before it goes out the door
predictive modeling is just simply
looking at providers and running through
their if there's a billion claims
probably every major hospital has
hundreds of thousands of claims a year
and just running through versus the me
and seeing where somebody has a spike if
somebody's you know massively over
billing MRI scans are massively over
billing for wheelchairs it's got great
potential to be able to look at trends
and look at you know sort of you know
where things are happening that are
inappropriate that look like fraud or
whether things that are happening that
look like it's actually just bad
medicine you've got big blue out there
number crunching all of the claims all
of the encounter data trying to find
anomalies there will be people who are
watching and saying hey your rate of
your test ordering has quadrupled in the
past six months what's going on there
let's figure that out are you
enthusiastic about the new attempts or
and and is there a reason to believe
that they'll be more successful I'm
hopeful that they'll be more successful
because I think they need to be more
successful I'm not particularly excited
because I'm not sure they completely get
it
the reason I'm optimistic is I think the
data that they have you know if you're
if you're gonna catch people the easiest
way to prioritize it sitting on it just
run on a broad net and chasing all
providers is to basically prioritize and
look for people in you know data runs
who have a trend of doing squirrely of
things I'm billing that would be great
it would be wonderful to see fifty sixty
seventy billion dollars in savings at
with no benefit changes I think we can
all agree that that's a good thing
it just doesn't seem very likely the
efforts haven't worked in the past they
don't look like they're really gonna
work in the future